B aus dem
Steig den dre
auf Preisschild Ken ich nicht von dech
und
Katana eine sch moin Christ altes Haus
und hallo
money ja ich habe meine zuschauerfagen
hier und ich ich kein Strike ansonsten
müssen wir noch pa Worte reden also die
erste Frage die ich habe ist wieso
bekommt einer wie du der im Prinzip
talentfrei ist außer 100 € Scheine vom
Papa verbrennen wieso bekommt einer wie
du ein Plattenvertrag und so Leute so
richtige Talente wie equitas oder max
noise nicht wieso bekommen solche guten
Musiker keinen
Plattenvertrag also meiner Meinung nach
ist überhaupt nicht wichtig ob man ein
Plattenvertrag hat oder nicht weil man
hat es ja bei mir genauso gesehen noch
vor irgendeinem Vertrag habe ich die
Leute erreicht habe ich Millionen Klicks
gehabt und jeder der Musik macht hat
dieselben Möglichkeiten wie ich auch
dieses Label hat mir oder dieser
Plattenvertrag hat mir keine im Grunde
keine anderen Möglichkeiten verschafft
die ich nicht schon davor gehabt habe
also jeder hat dasselbe Potenzial jeder
hat dieselben dieselbe
Ausgangsposition
drum das meine Sichtweise die Leute
entscheiden im Endeffekt people choice
die Leute entscheiden was sie hören
wollen was sie cool
finden die zweite Frage die ich habe ist
warum um alles in der Welt hängt in
deinen Videos an der Cappy ein
Preisschild okay diese Preisschild
Frage jetzt im Moment habe ich keins ich
hatte vorher gerade erst wieder ein Cap
auf noch mit Preisschild und price
tag ich komme aus dieser alten
hiphopschule und habe schon alle
möglichen Styles miterlebt ich verfolge
was die Rapper in den USA machen und
viele Modetrends kommen wieder gehen weg
die ersten Rapper haben ganz enge Jeans
gehabt dann kamen die Baggy Jeans jetzt
sind wieder eher diese Skinny Jeans in
und genauso dieses price tag gab's auch
schon als als modeatement schon in den
90er Jahren haben das Rapper gehabt und
die Bedeutung dahinter ist eigentlich so
ich habe ein ganz freshes Cap ich achte
drauf wie ich herumlaufe wie ich mich
Kleide und ich kaufe mir fresche Caps um
irgendwie immer fresh zu sein und drum
hängt das Preisschild noch dran dass der
Hintergrund einfach und ich habe einfach
versucht ein bisschen so Statement Mod
Statement zu machen und einfach ein
bisschen Swag auch rüber zuubringen und
die dritte und letzte Frage money Boy
was willst du eigentlich immer von
unseren Müttern stehst du so auf die ich
meine Mama der steht auf dich freust du
dich ne ja geil hey das finde ich krass
weil in dieser ganzen Rapszene und so
diese Frage ist eigentlich noch nie
gekommen ich hatte auf auf vielen frühen
Tracks und so das haben mir auch so
Leute die gar nicht so auf dem dem
rapfilm sind so z.B die Freundin von
meiner Mutter und so den ist es schon so
aufgefallen und so die haben gesagt weil
die das aber das das inind Raptexten
kommt das immer wieder mal vor so ich
fick deine Mutter oder
m also ist für mich nur so rapslang oder
so aber ganz unter uns so so reifere
Frauen haben schon gewiss anzi
Anziehungskraft und so aber da möchte
nicht allzu viel darüber
reden